foreign
what is covered quite extensively in the
dock and certainly was covered even more
extensively in the news was your
decision not that long ago to offer a
generous Severance packages to people
who
disagreed with your statements about
coybase as a mission-driven company that
provides a refuge of sorts with that
Focus that and please
correct my description if it doesn't fit
but and in so being a mission-driven
company wanting to avoid
sort of political and social
conversations within the company that
that chew up time and energy and
resources and attention
feel free to to set the table a little
better than I did but can you describe
the situation
the action
and then what is what is of greatest
interest to me is how you thought about
making the decision how you thought
about the possible ramifications of
making that decision and
prepared yourself
for what might happen and then what did
happen just weathering that
a few years back we put out this blog
post that coinbase was going to become a
mission focused company which basically
meant we were going to be a political
not focus on broader societal issues in
the workplace and so how did that all
come to be I mean really I'd say for the
couple of years prior to that
there was something that was sort of
bubbling up inside the company which
initially was very slow and subtle and I
didn't really pay too much attention to
it but eventually it culminated in a
walkout a bunch of employees being so
upset that they kind of closed their
laptops and decided not to come into
work in protest and that was sort of the
a big moment in the company history
because that had never happened before
and so what what led up to that well
basically there was a lot of you know
covet happened people were at home they
were probably had less of a sense of
belonging and cohesion as hey we're all
one company we're one group of people
we're all trying to do good stuff in the
world so there was a little bit of
frustration there there was probably a
lack of cohesion there and then I'd say
there just it became more popular in
society I've since gone back and read
some books on this like um you know
Jonathan Heights book about the
colleague of American mind and all these
things that kind of started on college
campuses I I sort of loosely read a few
things here and there about this but I
never really took it that seriously I
figured this was just you know there's
always been activism on college campuses
whatever we're trying to build something
in our company I didn't pay much
attention to it but what happened was we
started to get
basically more activism inside the
company whereas like initially I was
always thinking hey we're on the same
team we've got competitors we've got
Regulators we've got we're trying to
create all this change we're all on the
same team and internally people started
to think actually we're not all on the
same team my job is not to help the
coinbase mission it's to hold you know
speak truth to power or to hold
this other team you know to account or
something like that and so it manifested
in strange ways like at the Town Hall
meetings that we'd have every two weeks
we don't have an open mic q a and more
and more of the questions started to be
about things not really related to what
we were building as a company but to
about broader societal issues and it
almost became this this like thing where
who could make the exec team squirm the
most on stage and you know with these
very difficult questions and of course I
didn't have great answers to many of the
biggest broader societal issues we were
trying to all focus on building a more
more economic freedom in the world so as
I was noticing this was happening this
was around the time of the George Floyd
riots and everything like that and the
murder there and so there was a moment I
think where somebody in one of the All
Hands kind of came up and said um is
coinbase going to publicly support black
lives matter and I basically deferred to
answer the question I hadn't really read
that much about it I was like we're
gonna go look at this I don't know
to be determined and that wasn't good
enough and they kind of held the mic and
they pressed the issue and this is where
a bunch of people walked out of the
company so this was I was frankly
shocked I was like At first I was just
so surprised we all got in a room as an
exec team
and I I was like what I don't understand
what does coinbase have to do with
police brutality like we're not we're
not related to this but of course
this thing was erupting all over
societies all over the world and people
just felt every company every person
ever had to make some kind of a stand on
this and so it was a very difficult
leadership moment I remember calling
some people into the room telling me and
asking them what does BLM actually stand
for if we're going to go out there and
like say something positive about it and
you know they're like well it's
basically equality for you know people
and I was like great okay if that's what
people want to hear I don't understand
it but let's let's go out there and say
it and so I basically went out and made
a statement supporting BLM as many
companies did at that time and um people
came back to work which was fine but as
the months ticked by I started to feel
increasingly uneasy about it first of
all I subsequently learned that BLM
supported other things like around
defunding the police and all these
things which I was like all right we
shouldn't be getting involved in those
issues I I don't know what our point of
view is on that and I I basically
realized there was not a clear
agreement amongst all the people in the
company that some people felt the
company should actually be engaging in
broader societal issues to try to go
help out and other people felt that we
should be focused on our mission which
was a very big and important thing
already
increasing economic freedom in the world
with crypto and I was in that ladder
camp and I felt like that's already a
big enough thing to focus on we can't be
jumping to every issue of of the month
or the year we have to try to focus it
might take 10 20 years for us to make a
dent in that problem that's a really big
thing so I realized the company was
divided on this issue and I was kind of
failing as a leader if I didn't come out
and make it clear and so I basically
after a couple months of deliberating
and this is where you're asking about my
thought process
I was really torn about this this is
where I sat down to write and I tried to
write a blog post because when I try to
formulate my thinking I try to write so
I wrote probably two or three or four
drafts of this where I just discarded it
and tried to write it over again and I
was reading books talking to people at
this time I eventually settled on this
language Around Mission first
and I remember
sharing it with some leaders inside the
company and with our board and there was
some people inside the company who were
like you know do not share this under
any circumstances this is this will be a
terrible thing for the company and I was
like I know it's going to be
controversial but we have to solve this
problem right like I don't really care
so much about a couple bad headlines I
care if we're are we building an aligned
culture that can actually accomplish
this Mission long term
and some people told me things like you
know an underrepresented person will
never work at this company again and I
was like really is that true I went and
talked to some of our employee resource
groups and they told me I asked them
what's the most important thing to you
want to work at this company they're
like we just want to be respected at
work like learn things be able to build
cool stuff it was basically what
everybody else wanted and so from
talking with people directly my hunch
was that was not going to actually play
out but that was a fear people had and I
think the thing that finally pushed me
over the line to do it because I'm kind
of a conflict diverse person by Nature I
didn't really want to be known for this
but I think the thing that pushed me
over the line was I was thinking like
God like the CEO job is just not that
fun to be honest like if I have to come
in every day and be put in front of the
hot mic and like have to answer all
these crazy things that I don't have an
answer to
that's not what I signed up for I want
to build cool stuff with technology that
changes the world that's what I'm good
at and so I was basically thinking like
either I have to go if this is just what
the job of being a tech CEO is in modern
day I've got to go because this is not
fun for me or they've got to go and from
talking to a couple of friends and
mentors and whatnot I basically realized
they've got to go and it was strange
because it felt like such a vocal it
felt like maybe it was 50 of the company
or something but it wasn't it was a very
vocal tiny percentage of the company and
so I basically made this exit package
available I said look this is the
direction we're going in if you're not
if you're not okay with that I totally
get it I didn't make it clear up front
that's my fault so we're going to give
this great severance package whatever
five percent of the company left
it created a bunch of drama for a few
months a couple journalists wrote hit
pieces on us and things like that but
afterwards it was it was better it was
like one of the best things I've ever
done for the company to be honest
because now we're fully aligned we're
making faster progress everybody who
joins the company knows what they're
signing up for and it was an incredibly
important leadership moment for me
because I was terribly scared to do do
it I didn't want the controversy I knew
it was people were going to hate it
and so yeah hopefully that gives us some
clarity no it does and it just for
clarity hopefully you don't feel I'm
asking this question to make you squirm
that's not the objective I'm genuinely
curious about the thought process
surrounding what is inevitably on some
level going to be an unpopular decision
right and I think that is a Hallmark of
good leadership otherwise I mean you're
just taking votes and consensus and
doing what the larger
group would do anyway right so it seems
to me that integral to effective
leadership is
having the ability to make
unpopular decisions when it is in the
best interest long term of the company
and the mission in this case right yeah
that is that is why I asked so thank you
for answering totally